et que je retiens d'abord au plan
national pour la Bourgogne et aussi pour
mon département de l'Yonne c'est la
volonté très forte des Français dans
finir avec les années Holland de
sanctionner le Parti socialiste première
idée ce que je retiens aussi c'est une
véritable colère une exaspération qui
s'est manifestée et qui fait porter sur
nous la droite qui est au responsabilité
dans ces départements une très lourde
responsabilité parce qu'il faut qu'on
produise des résultats faut qu'on agisse
très concrètement de manière très rapide
pour apporter des solutions aux
problèmes que se posent les gens j'ai
pas de triomphalisme c'est une victoire
bien sûr c'est d'abord une défaite du
Parti socialiste et c'est une victoire
pour ceux qui doivent maintenant
apporter des solutions aux Français faut
pas qu'on s'endorme sur nos lauriers en
criant victoire il y a une victoire
non mais surtout ce que je constate
écoutez il faudrait être aveugle pour
pas s'en rendre compte il y a d'abord eu
une colère une exaspération lorsque le
Front National est présent dans
l'immense majorité des cantons au second
tour ça veut dire que les Français
disent d'abord aux partis de
gouvernement d'abord ils disent à
Hollande votre politique on n'en vaut
plus c'est aussi ce qu'ils disent à
Françoise du travail globalement et puis
ils disent aussi à la droite ben voilà
occupez-vous de nous produisez des
résultats c'est une très grande exigence
qui pèse sur nous il y a vraiment
urgence obtenir des résultats pour les
frais ou est-ce qu'ils disent
globalement on est malheureux on sent
pas bien est-ce qu'il demande est-ce
qu'il demande quelque chose de concret
bien sûr
ce que ce que demande vraiment les
Français dans tous les cantons sur
lesquels
nous confiant les clés du pouvoir
départemental en Côte-d'Or dans l'Yonne
en Saône-et-Loire et dans l'immense
majorité des départements de France ce
qui nous demande c'est de réussir dans
des départements sur des sujets concrets
comment est-ce qu'on peut ou pas mieux
aider les PME à créer des emplois
comment est-ce qu'on peut lutter contre
le chômage comment est-ce qu'on lutte
contre la désertification médicale etc
etc puis nous disent aussi et ça je
m'exprime comme député national pour le
coup il faut que le gouvernement change
de change de cap voilà c'est une
sanction très forte Manuel Valls pourra
pas nous dire mardi à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'on ne change rien c'est pas
possible on peut pas faire comme avant
en discutant des mêmes projets de loi
absurdes il faut absolument que le
gouvernement entendent le message des
Français les Français disent à Monsieur
Hollande à Monsieur Valls à Madame
tobira et aux autres changer de
politique